foreign
[Music]
champions of this realm can do nothing
to stop us
you are very menacing I just want you to
know that
[Music]
a lot has changed in the last few years
the wizard gave me superpowers
and then everybody got super powers
all right here's the situation
the daughters of Atlas are coming to
hunt Us
children's told the power of the Gods
he ripped it from our father's call okay
I feel like maybe I should be riding all
this down you lost the powers child your
world will not survive this
you want these Powers come get them hey
Khaleesi
all right
we have one job to do save the world
finally
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I can't do this take my powers back you
came to me so you would take them back
right
I speak Millennia
searching for worthy champion
you've known exactly what must be done
Billy what are you doing I have to do
this we end this now yeah
we do
nowhere
[Music]
foreign